hi everyone
my name is philip i'm a machine learning
engineer and hugging phase and the tech
lead for the aws
partnership welcome to this walkthrough
of the newest amazon search maker
features
in this walkthrough we are going to take
a look at the new
aws hanging face deep learning
containers
and the new hacking phase framework
extension for the python amazon
sagemaker sdk
we are going to fine-tune a text
classification transformer using the new
hyenface dlc and
sagemaker sdk the model will be trained
on the imdb
dataset for movie reviews before we get
started
um i wanted to let you know that you can
find the sample notebooks
and other sample notebooks and
documentation on hangingface.co
amazon there's also a detailed blog post
about the partnership with all the
benefits we are going to provide you
as customer
for our example we are using the amazon
search maker studio which is a web-based
machine learning ide
for training transformer model directly
in aws
with the integrated permission
management
so as you can see here right now i have
my notebook up and running
i'm running on a small t3 instance and
yeah let's get started you can find this
notebook as mentioned on the hugging
face
dot co slash amazon site and for our
example as mentioned we are
training an end-to-end binary text
classification model
using transformers and data sets for
training and pre-processing our data and
i will show you our fine tuning script
later
the first step we need to do is to to
install
the transformers library and the data
sets with the s3 extension
in our stagemaker studio
okay as we have now installed everything
we can
move forward the first and important
step is to to yeah to configure our
sagemaker session and get the right
credentials
in sagemaker you can define a sagemaker
session bucket
which if it is not created um sagemaker
will create it
and the sagemaker or this bucket is used
for
storing all your informations during
training
our data set will be uploaded to there
our trained model at the end will upload
it
there we have our logs and metrics will
also be located so if you
have a central point of all the
information for a training job
okay the next step is to to check if we
have um
yeah if our sagemaker hugging phase
integration is available
it is nice okay we have set up our
sagemaker session we created our session
backend we configured our um yeah
aws region where our training job will
run the next step is
pre-processing and our data in the new
extension you can either pre-process
your data in advance and provide
the pre-processed data set in your
training job
or you can do it inside a training job
in this example
i decided that we do the pre-processing
in advance
so here's a yeah a few code snippets
where we are going to load
our imdb dataset with the datasets
library
and load the tokenizer from the hub from
the hanging phase hub
create a helper function of humpty
function for tokenizing it
tokenizing our train and test data set
in the example i sample down the test
data set so we don't have
to wait um when doing training
and at the end we are just um yeah
setting the format to torch
since we are using pytorch as our base
framework for this example
um i will not do this right now
because it takes a few minutes and this
should be a very yeah
easy and light walk through but it works
after we have pre-processed our data set
we are going to use the new file system
integration for data sets
where we can directly save our
pre-processed
data set to s3 the only thing we need to
do is to define
yeah ns3 uri where the training set will
be located therefore we use our default
bucket
with a s3 prefix we defined earlier for
for naming our data set so we'll have
our sagemaker session bucket
slash imdb slash strain and for
for tests we are doing the same
okay so
as i i mentioned earlier we
introduced a new sdk it's very similar
to the existing
such as for tensorflow or for pytorch
the the new sdk is built not only by aws
we from the hugging phase side
also help them to build a nice sdk to
provide you developer the best
experience on fine tuning transformer
models on amazon sagemaker
and if you have any feedback or yeah
important news for us please let us know
the estimator
is basically a class instance of where
you define everything
sage maker needs for your training job
we have an entry point where
our train yeah script is located we
define our sagemaker session we can give
our training job a name we define the
instance type
on which the training will be run we
define the instance count so here you
can basically
scale up from one to as many instances
you want to run
distributed draining for example and
then we define our hyperparameters
which will be passed in as name
arguments so
you can imagine these dictionaries will
be converted to
this named argument for the training set
for our fine tuning script we are using
a
pretty basic example using the trainer
from transformers
and um yeah basic configuration
basically
a training script in sagemaker is a
normal python script with
main method and you the first
thing you need to do in your find unique
script is to to yet to set up
an argument parser since the
hyperparameters will be passed in as
named arguments if you don't have any
hyperparameters feel free to leave it
out
in our examples we are going to pass in
the epochs
the batch size and the model names for
most of the arguments i
defined default arguments but for the
model name for examples
i didn't define any defaults so we are
need to to yet to pass in the
hyperparameter for our model
into our fine tuning script
after we have passed our arguments um we
are setting up
yeah a logger to get all the
informations we want from our training
script sagemaker is
um forwarding the logs to our
cli and it's saving them to cloud watch
so
if you run your sagemaker job
asynchronously
which mean that you start and don't wait
until it's done
you can up look up your logs later in
cloudwatch
okay next step is load our data set as
um or since we have uploaded our data
sets to s3
sagemaker have downloaded them in
advance
on the machine where the training job is
run
and then we can use the load from disk
method from the data sets library to
load our pre-processed um
data sets that's it we are logging
information about the length then we
define a compute
function for for evaluation later
the next step is creating our model
instance
where we are using our passed in model
name parameter for
loading the model from the app then we
define our training arguments
which will be used in the training
here you can see we are also using the
epochs from
that we pass in the batch size and then
we create our trainer instance
with our model our arguments our custom
compute
metrics function pass in our train and
data set
and then we run trainer.train after
training is done we run trainer.evaluate
with our evaluation data set save the
results
in a text file which will be also
uploaded to s3 later
and then save our models to our model
directory
and that's basically it
okay so here you can see we have the the
hyper parameters we are going to pass in
and as model name we are using the
distal bird model
batch size of 16 running one epoch i
think it's enough for our
small little example then we we create
our estimator give it a last check on
our hyperparameters and then we can run
estimator.fit and pass in our train and
test input parameters and here train
input path is our s3 uri
to our directory on s3
that's it our training is now finished
um
as you can see sagemaker has forwarded
all the locks from our
training to the console if we would have
invoked or run the training
asynchronously
we could see these locks in cloudwatch
and here you can see uh sagemaker's
logging into the training environment
and we have all the environment
variables uh
which are accessible in our training
shop then we have
the locks from our training script where
you can see our
train data set length our test data set
length
and the metrics from our
yeah evaluation as a
evaluation accuracy we have 92 percent
and also the training took around 935
seconds which is roughly about
15 minutes so it's pretty nice um worth
mentioning is that you
only need to adjust like two lines of
code to use or to run
sagemaker distributed training and we
have integrated
data distribution directly into the
trainer and model library is also
integrated into a sagemaker
trainer i hope you like the walkthrough
if you have any questions or feedback
feel free to
open a new thread on our hanging face
forum or open a github issue
you